[Música]
hoje vou ensinar conter polícia
primeiro acho que dá porque mo no bairro
que moram é isto que supostamente os
karatecas e este estudo sarro isto mas é
provável que você não tenha estão tainá
problema
dra usava o pão
quer dizer que o roupão
o cabelo é opcional como a fita e agora
parte mais importante
vou ensinar o que fazer com um martelo
ninja como estas
e para isso vai precisar de uma
impressora a 4 usar só uma cor vai ficar
como esta que não é muito bonita mas
produtos das duas cores diferentes e vai
fazer um contrato muito bonito como isto
é muito pior seja com duas folhas
conseguirá fazer duas telas ninjas e
poderá atender contra o mal e agora
inspira o tutorial muita atenção a todos
os pormenores
[Música]
stagione corajoso para fazer projetos e
utilizar uma folha de papel a4 emissora
não estarem só uma folha ficar mostrando
a mesma cor não fiquem coisa fica mais
nítido se forem duas coisas podem ver
agora é para eu fazer essa aqui seja
usar duas folhas de papel impressora 1
azul e uma branca e prata com essas duas
folhas não consegui fazer duas telas
como oeste está com os ares
o primeiro cuidado prata foi assim
para fazer para enquadrar as coisas
estiverem folha de papel já com formato
quadrado
escusando fazer espaço e agora dobrar
assim
[Música]
e vamos cortar e chefe aq khan o fluxo
na escola e brincar várias vezes ter
arriscado então usar motor mantém um
cheque para resgatar rita buzzar lançou
esta parte que não vai ser preciso
dobrar a mãe
[Música]
para vincar mais cedo
e cortar
[Música]
espero que tenham gostado da minha
dentro de campo tanto que agora tem
manoel ouro e prata
agora vou cortar uma parte e esta não
vou guardar fazer o quarto principal
estratégia do mec pode pegar papel de
protagonista já tem outra parte foi a
tesoura e foi dobrar ao pai em carvalho
continua a trabalhar de quilo cada um se
ficar mal do prazo
o standard problema agora mesmo estou a
ouvir já pode fazer duas partes iguais
[Música]
uma pequena diferença será cobrada a
calma e mexe a abertura do mai efe ks
integrada uma palavra a sede de abertura
ficasse lá e vai ajudar a mãe
[Música]
quero bem
sempre teve em carvalho já chateia mas
por um tempo importantíssimo brincar vai
hoje dar certo e agora enfrentamos
portelinha vai celebrar na direção dessa
aqui pode verificar ferramenta minha
[Música]
pronto agora instalado
vou tentar mesclar mexer na direção da
outra parte vocês vão ficar agora com um
conjunto das duas partes e que ouvir a
performance de branco para fotos
[Música]
e mesmo que este lar onde é óbvio né
essa m e guaraqueçaba
esta parte aqui com esta partilha luxe
criar uma à outra
assim fica aqui uma espécie de trenzinho
enquanto agora e já contrário a pressão
e aos 42 apps não vai ficar antenada
contrário
[Música]
assim é só para fazerem assim hoje
petróleo
era pra quê
[Música]
aí o carro de bruno galini e meio para
está agora poderá contar com uma das
partes aquela que viramos porém em cima
da outra festa ou subir por isso e
centralizado o que vai ficar é uma bruxa
tempo nazista
nas duas rodas influenciado mas somente
a parte fica por baixo brasil outro lado
só para marcar mais
voltar à posição inicial e um pacto em
que você fica em cima e voltar por cima
e por isso é prudente intensa nesta fase
o standard dentro das chaves nesta parte
porque por baixo
[Música]
isto é capaz de ficar muito centralizado
agora virá contrário à justiça nesta
partida e vamos centralizar e podem
vetar de ficar pelado não dá para se
preservar em outro lado do n
eu estava e ficou centralizado seja um
fã de ver esta coisa 34 parte da
história de amor enquanto agora já está
entrosado com poder parar até que dois
bons e vamos introduzir estas duas
partes bons brasil de carvalho esta
parte inclusive um golpe de estado
lembre que os alunos que não conseguirem
cumprir pode ser actor escola e já fiz
mas desta vez já tem que ficar feliz
quanto agora mesclada com junichi
é importante
[Música]
espero também que se está aqui a partida
difícil
agora é sobre trocar né